rétro pour soi que c'est pas parce que
je t'aime profondément ça fait des
années que je le connais depuis vingt
ans ouais et j'ai toujours su que tu
étais un très gros mois et a toujours
été fidèle en amitié aussi ça faut le
dire tu me suis dit ce qui m'a fait
super plaisir c'est que cet été à chaque
fois je me baladais et jean bizet ou et
booder parce que je suis ton fils on a
reçu le test ce matin que les pères oui
j'irai à marrakech demande après toi
tout le temps veut l'héritage c'est ça
bah oui aussi un trek a bien gratter ne
dirais pas non bouder qui viennent nous
voir pour un livre aussi à bouder on
apprend plein de trucs sur madère à ce
que vous dites n'a pas l'habitude de
cuivre et non mais non et là tu te livre
beaucoup
ouais non mais c'est vrai comme
saisonnier est vrai rouge et j'ai trouvé
ça top parce que c'est toi qui résume le
mieux le livre tu dis le but ce n'est
pas que je vous raconte ma vie
le but c'est que vous fasse comprendre
ma vie mes échecs mais réussit mes
conneries aussi on va pas se mentir tout
ce que je sais vous montrer qu'avec de
la volonté on peut arriver à tout et
c'est ce que tu dis alors tu reviens sur
ta vie on apprend plein de choses
notamment à propos de ta tu dis ta
différence tu parles de ta différence ce
site la naissance très compliqué tu dis
que le tout début de ta vie a été
compliqué pour toi et ta famille
pourquoi
non parce que je suis né au maroc en
1978 je suis né j'étais un bébé qui est
né avec avec un asthme et à l'époque
qu'on en 78 dans un village marocain
l'asthme on connaît pas at war et le
docteur quand il m'a mis enfin le
docteur qui était aussi mécanicien est
plein comme plâtre
[Rires]
il connaissait pas ça donc j'avais du
mal à respirer il à dire maintenant à ma
maman lui a dit ben cet enfant là
normalement si tout se passe bien il
passera pas l'hiver ça ouais voilà et
mon papa qui était ici en france et qui
travaillaient ici en france et il a dit
dans cette enfant va vivre et puis et
puis voilà je raconte tout le
cheminement maman jusqu'à paris c'est le
début du livre ne cessa et donc voilà et
laurie je reviens sur ça parce que c'est
vrai que je profite de ma seule ambition
aussi pour dire parce que beaucoup de
gens quand on va sur internet on tape
bouder on traite des noms de maladies de
fou non non mais si vous les vrais il a
le skip innogy la latitude seule ma tête
je suis pas malade
moi ça me fait rire mais malheureusement
j'ai beaucoup de mamans et beaucoup de
parents qui m'écrivent en me disant
voilà monfils n'a la même maladie que
vous mais moi je suis pas malade
c'est compliqué une mère en détresse que
t'es pas maladroit et donc voilà je peux
alors ta maman elle part alors du maroc
à la rizza paris pour rejoindre ton père
tu vas passer un nom à l'hôpital des
enfants
il a tu dis la france m'aura donné mes
premiers bouts d'oxygène exactement
c'est vrai que je le vois à chaque fois
tu aime profondément la france
bah je suis français ouais je sais mais
je suis à aimer la roumanie j'ai rien à
voir et à lire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je fais parfois il ya des trucs que tu
vois en france qui te font de la peine
mais c'est ouais nan mais j'aime bien
sûr mais on est français d'abord on a
des origines bien sûr je suis aussi
marocain je suis citoyen du monde mais
un français oui parce qu'on a grandi en
france on a étudié en france on a tout
fait en france et ça me peine quand
j'entends un mythe la france par exemple
tu vois semaine c'est du mal parce que
non c'est vrai on est bien en france
quand même j'avais un coup dans mon
spectacle aussi tu vois et c'est en
france que j'ai eu beau mon premier
bouder attendaient afin de gérer accès à
bouder et voilà en fait c'est ce que je
raconte dans le livre
tous ces airs qui ont été coupées par
des obstacles et à chaque fois qu'un
nouvel erp qui décrit en acteur